hello everyone and welcome back to the
world rapid championship after his
victory in round 3 over Anton Corbijn
ali reza now faces sergey Kerrigan
so it's it's a really a beautiful game
and really educational one so I do hope
you enjoy it I'm sure you're gonna enjoy
it because it's just the whole battle
the front of all game is basically a
struggle of over the d5 square which you
know usually happens in a Sicilian but
like many of you I'm also very
interested to see if others I can also
do something against an elite player
like Sergei kurakin so let's dive
straight into it well Cara can opens
with E 4 and we have C 5 and the last
game we've seen how Ali Reza takes down
the denied of defence now we get to see
how our reza plays it denied our defence
so d 6 we have d four characters
captures Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and
of course a6 the knight of Defense's on
the board and the kurakin goes for
Bishop to d3 we have E 5 pushing the
knight back Knights - E - Ari
maneuvering the night over to g3 Bishop
to e7 and here correcting just castles
we have castles by Ferrara and night
the g3 now with control of the of the f5
Square and here Bishop to e6 is the most
played move but rook to e8 is what I'll
get is it has been played once so far
but it's still not a new move so here we
have Bishop to c4 Knight to d5 is a
non-moving disposition but Bishop to c4
which kurakin plays is a new move in the
position so it is already as a move 10
that we have a completely new game and
it's again a move directed towards
controlling the d5 square so Bishop to
e6 all it is a counter is the bishop and
now Knight the d5 just getting the nice
- a nice central outpost with Knight B
to d7 preparing Knight b6 the turkic
away the bishop with Bishop to e3 and
now rook the c8 also kicking away the
bishop just Bishop back to b3 and Bishop
to f8 now the bishop will be very useful
guarding the Kings side but also the
rook is now controlling the the e-file
so at some point if you will be able to
push d5 d5 will have sufficient
protection so c3
if knife to c5 comes now you can just
push push back the bishops so you don't
have to give up the disappear we have
Queen to a5 and now comes Knight
captures on f6 as the knight on d5 was
under heavy fire with Knight captures on
f6 and now Bishop to g5 this is how
kirkin fights for the d5 square now
again attacking one of the defenders of
the d5 square now Knight to d7 ally Reza
prepares a knight to c5 to kick away the
bishop or or to just capture it as it is
one of the defenders of the d5 square
and here best for Kerrigan is Bishop to
e3 but the problem with Bishop to e3 is
that it allows our eyes at the repeat
Knight f6 and then we could actually see
a repetition here you know just just a
nice draw in a move 16 you know with a
repetition of moves because everyone
wants to control d5 but Kerrigan is not
interested in that he goes Queen to e2
and now we have Knights to c5 attacking
the bishop Bishop captures on e6 with
Knight captures an e6 now as the bishop
here is under attack and the bishop
moves Bishop the back to e3 and now that
finally d5 is the possibility of it as a
pushes it and here we have it d5 so if
if you're playing black here and you've
executed d5 against someone like Sergei
kirkin you you feel really awesome about
yourself with a capture Sun d5 Queen
captures on d5 and rook fd1 Kerrigan
puts a row can be open on the only open
file on the board Queen back to c6 and
now Queen to g4 preparing to remover the
Queen over to the Queen side there are
no attacking chances here senses the
bishop and night really do a fine job
guarding the black king we have g6 and
now comes f3
we have Bishop to c5 viraja offers a
trader for light square Bishop Bishop
captures Kirk and obliges Queen captures
and King to h1 and now rook c2 d 8f Rosa
says I'm very very happy with my
position we can just trade all the ropes
or what you know off the board and then
even though you have a three-to-two
advantage on the Queen side it's really
not a problem once b5 comes so here we
have Quinta e4
pressure on b7 fraud offenses with b5
and Queen back to C - now just guarding
the rook and also if perhaps b4 comes
you you might be able to advance the
pawn with c4 and create a passport but
with f5 by ferocious and now Queen to b3
at putting the pressure on tonight so
now root cap versus a threat Knight
cannot capture and if rook captures then
we'll just win captors night so we came
to f7 defending the knight on e6 and now
comes a four by Kuryakin Queen the c-4
offering a queen trade now and attacking
the Queen
so now Queen captures and c4 you could
also move the Queen back but kurakin is
you know confident that he can hold this
with pawn captures and c4 and now like I
said Kerrigan has a three-to-two
advantage on the Queen side but the see
the c c4 pawn that takes care of both of
these pawn so it's like you don't you're
not up upon on the Queen side with
Knight to f1 hoping to get 93 and
they're good to go after the c4 pawn but
now rook to d3 and now if you capture
then your black just gets a nice pass
pawn on d3 and once efore is played it's
just game over so here we have and also
the you cannot go Knights to d2 because
a rook today just wins the game you lose
material here so look the e1 putting
pressure on the pawn here but now Knight
c5 the point is nicely protected King g1
preparing to bring the King into the
game but f4 taking away all the squares
from from the night here the night is
now not entering the game we're rookie
to getting the rook to the second rank
to help out with the defense but now e
for we have pawn captures rook captures
we have characters captures and now rook
to e1 attacking the knight but now
Knights the c5 and this is a problem if
you activate the rook you can no longer
control you're a four point so now if
you go back it's just the rookin a one
for the rest of the game guarding that
a4 pawn and black has all the time in
all the time in the world to improve his
position well white can't really
do anything so he decided to play a five
to keep his rook active but now rook to
d5 now after the knight moves all of
these pawns will be under attack and
here since there are no good squares for
the night Kirk in makes one so now the
h2 is a square available for the night
but King f6 we have night h2 King f5
taking away the g4 Square from whites
night we have Knight to f3 and now just
nice to d3 attacking the rook attacking
the b2 point attacking the a five point
we have rook to e7 going after the h7
point but now other Reza says okay two
points are better than one
so rook characters on a5 Brooke address
on h7 and Knight captures and b2 so here
it's a Lovaza who is now up upon really
really just impressive stuff this is you
know this is the good stuff that happens
if you manage to you know pull of d5 in
a Sicilian and then just not be worse so
look the f7 check with King e4 and all
the rest is extremely low on time here
but like we already mentioned for our
residents that's really not a problem
with King h2 and now Knight to d1 going
after the c3 pawn but also preparing
some very nasty threats towards the
white king we Luke d7 now hoping for if
Knight characters will be for check
pushes the King back after since c4 and
the game continues
but alga Reza prefers Knight e3 he wants
to get look here you can just threaten
the g2 pawn for example so rook the d6
hoping to win it back at least one more
pawn before he starts defending but you
should really go Rudy for check push the
King back and try and take it from there
however after night to e3 rook the d6
displayed by Kerrigan and now holidays
that goes for it Knight g4 check we have
King gauge 3 9 f to check King h2 and
now Luke a1 already threatening mate
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail so non IG 1 you have to defend
against mate with Knight back to g4 with
check King h1 and not nice to be 5 and
you can look just you know observe
disposition and see how beautiful it is
the night guards the c-4 pond the night
guards the g6 pawn the king guards the
f4 pawn white doesn't have a useful move
so you can't move the knight you can
waste movies with the King and if you do
nothing the a point we'll just start
marching down the board so here a car
contracting h2 but now rook a to the
threatening f3 since the G pawn is
pinned King back to h1 but now just a5
and here car can play Knight to f3 but
it doesn't help him he activated the
night but only briefly so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
best continuation for black while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations we already mentioned the
line only now it's it's even better
because the rook lands on a one with
check and for the Duke we just want to
enjoy the show
it's rooked a1 check so congratulations
on finding it and it was in this
position on more 54 that Sarah Cain
resigned the game he resigned as there
is nothing more to be done here
if King h2 then you just meet the white
king an IG for Czech English 3 night of
to check King here and now we already
have a rockin a1 so rook h1 is made and
if you don't if you try and blocking
with Nyjah 1 then you just start you
know continue advancing your past pawn
king h2 it's not a problem just 83 you
don't have a good move you put a room
behind the past pawn just a - you waste
a move because you don't have any moves
you go night g4 check King h1 and now
King III threatening King F 2 with King
captures on g1 mate so here again White
has no moves you can try and prolong the
game Ruki a checking if - look here
checking g3 but now it's over any movie
playing rook captures night is coming
and then you just advance the pawn all
the way to win the game like rugby - it
doesn't really matter captures captures
and you don't even need a queen you can
bring a rook in the game
blocks and now row captures and b1 will
be made just thought you might enjoy
seeing how how to win the same game the
point is white doesn't have
of a pond is is just winning so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I mean I definitely have I really enjoy
games where you know black really
outperforms white in the night of end is
able to push d5 it's just the beautiful
stuff and against someone an elite
player like Sarah Kerrigan that is quite
an accomplishment so you know just you
know taking down Anton Corbijn round 3
taking down Kerrigan in round 4 and in
round 5 Alireza faces a young feast of
Duda who is also doing exceptionally
well and I think that it will be the
game to cover next so we'll see how it
goes well I once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Doug
McNab Edward Baker Maxime piece an
extreme 1998 and Turin spike for a
contributor to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the well the coverage of the
feed a world rabbit championship so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day